on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight a Facebook and uncensored as
President Biden pardons pot users
Britain reportedly considers locking
them up we'll debate marijuana laws of
Happy Mondays Maverick Sean Ryder
Jewish Superstars United condemn Kanye
West races tirades I'll speak live to
comedy actor and friend star Michael
Rapaport who's furious with Kanye
for taking dementia time bomb on an
aging population the husband of the late
great dane Barbara Windsor will be here
live in the studio
and this trust they shall cut taxes and
the national debt but she won't cut
public spending
finally lost her marbles
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening for London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensive prime
minister Liz truss got about two days in
office before the Queen's death and a
period National morning she then had
another two days behind the desk before
Parliament packed up for party
conferences and she's had three days at
work this week so in the seven days of
service to this country she so far costs
the UK Market 300 billion pounds in
value which is roughly 43 billion pounds
a day you certainly can't say she's not
efficient every time mistrust speaks we
seem to get poorer and today at Prime
Minister's questions she reminded us why
what we're making sure is that we
protect our economy at this very
difficult time internationally and as a
result as a result of our action Mr
Speaker and this has been independently
corroborated we will see higher growth
and lower inflation
really corroborated by who exactly
quasi-quarting
the IMF actually said yesterday that
growth will grind to a near hold of 0.3
percent next year inflation will be
higher in the UK than anywhere in the
Eurozone other than the mighty Slovakia
a report by The Institute for fiscal
studies meanwhile says there's a 60
billion pound black hole in the mini
budget needing massive public spending
cuts obviously didn't post a copy to
number 10.
during her leadership contest the Prime
Minister said and I quote her exactly
I'm very clear I'm not planning public
spending reductions is she going to
stick to that absolutely
absolutely sure prime minister tax cuts
lower national debt more spending no
government Cuts either you're a very
secretive secret economic genius or
something's not quite adding up here but
to give the trust had you credit there
was one short moment of absolute Crystal
Clear Clarity and brutal honesty from
the Prime Minister today
I'm just Mr Speaker I'm genuinely
unclear about what language
Mr Speaker I'm genuinely unclear
as guarantee well he could have stopped
it after Mr Speaker I'm genuinely
unclear couldn't you we're all unclear
no one's got a clue what Liz truss and
quasi-quarting are doing it makes
absolutely no sense to be slashing taxes
at this moment in time with the
country's finances and the state they're
in to then try and pretend you're not
going to cut public spending to pay for
all this is Cloud Cuckoo Land stuff
even as I come on air tonight there's a
slew of tweets which I think are very
revealing
this is from talktv's Kate McCann a
trust supporter
post mistrust's appearance in the 22
committee room tonight I mean she's
cardboard isn't she we have to accept
that to which Kate McCann said but
that's not going to win your election is
it of course not can the reply we're
going to lose nothing makes any
difference now we're effed
and just in it of these particular
letters Robert Preston tweeted a member
of trust's own cabinet a cabinet
minister tells me trust and quieting's
governance is so dire that some Tory MPS
would vote against it in a confidence
vote preferring even a general election
that costs them their seats to the
current economic chaos
isn't that extraordinary in seven
working days this new prime minister
lost the markets lost many of her own
MPS lost some of her cabinet and clearly
lost most of the public
I think the best thing that this trust
can do now and I mean it's completely
seriously it's called an election or
quit she has no mandate for the Mayhem
that she is creating
well more on that later but first
tonight President Biden last week
pardoned all Americans committed to
possessing marijuana it's a stark
contrast to the starts to the British
Home Secretary reportedly wants to make
cannabis a Class A drug alongside crack
heroin and crystal meth UK governments
now distanced himself from the sweller
bravements stars but it's rehashed to
Classic debate it's cannabis a dangerous
gate gateway drug or a sociable sedative
no worse than alcohol worth potentially
billions in tax revenues we're joining
me now to discuss this a formal
newspaper that is Emily Sheffield
political journalist Ava Santina talk TV
contributor Esther kraku but also lead
singer of the Happy Mondays and
self-proclaimed melon twister Sean Ryder
and the Fox News contributor across the
pond Tommy layron so let me start with
Sean uh a great decision
I praise you all right good to see now
this is a raging debate and I spent a
lot of time in America where in 19
States now marijuana is legal uh for
American citizens it all to be said not
for not for uh non-american citizens and
and come to Tommy in a moment for her
very on how that's all been going but
certainly massively more open about
legalizing this drug in America than we
are here which seems a little perverse
do you think that we should be catching
up with the Americans and moving to
Legalize It
well I'm going to be quite
controversially at piercing Carl Leon's
second Senate a knob
because Draconian rules that you know
Tunica Class A I mean what's that going
to achieve that's just ridiculous it's
Draconian and yeah you know I really
thought whatever happens in America
whether it's 10 years 20 years it
happens here and we should be taxing it
and we should be making money off it
really you know we need to go forward
you know
going backwards you know we need to try
something that hasn't been tried before
in terms of cannabis itself
your doctor well sure famously cannabis
no one's ever OD'd on cannabis right
it's it's impossible pretty much they're
not it's no recorded case of somebody
having a lethal overdose of cannabis
however I you know I was yeah I've been
lazy well I was discussing it though
before we came on there with some of my
own team and they they have family
members some of them who've had
extremely bad experiences
um by taking too much marijuana and you
do read a lot of grim stories about
people who get addicted to it it ruins
their lives it's a gateway drug to more
serious drugs what do you say to that
argument
well cannabis has got a built-in
antidote right and the basic thing about
it is you light up and smoke it and if
you get paranoid you know you stop
smoking it you know once you you know I
mean I smoke for 15 17 years ago one
morning lit up a giant usual thing wake
up skin up
and I got Potter and I had another goal
and I got powder and I didn't smoke it
again and that's the same with all my
mates you know and everybody I know so
once you start getting better you stop
smoking it
there really isn't any long-term you
know I I'm not having it you know about
there's no withdrawal symptoms they're
not physical withdrawal symptoms they're
more mental you know I want it that
lasts for about a week so
um you know these
it's just ridiculous it really is
Draconian okay let's come to Tommy uh
it's ridiculous and Draconian that the
new British Home Secretary is
considering making this a Class A drug
and incarcerating people for at the
exact moment President Biden is doing of
course the opposite with Americans in
relation to marijuana how do you think
this conversion of many American states
to places where Americans can legally
take this drug how is that gone Tommy
well I'll tell you this I don't usually
believe in Freedom infringement of
really any kind but I'll tell you the
states that have legalized in the United
States if you look at them and you look
at their homeless population their
degenerate population it has expanded
wildly I mean just look at Denver
Colorado it used to be a city that was
very vibrant very hard working and then
they legalized pot and now they have
potheads laying on the side of the
street they have people that travel
there because pot was legalized so I
don't think it attracts the best of the
best you know here in the United States
we allow the states to decide and I'm
honestly an advocate for states rights I
think if you want to have a class of
people that are potheads that smoke weed
that maybe don't contribute a whole lot
to society your voters need to decide
that but I would tell you tread lightly
on this whole legalize everything
because we've also got States here in
the United States that have said Hey
listen heroin all those other illicit
drugs they're not so bad either we have
shoot up galleries where you can safely
inject I mean we talk about a Snowball
Effect that's what you're seeing in the
United States so be careful what you
wish for it might seem like it's just
all in good fun just a little weed until
you've got pothead littering your
streets and then you might think a
little different Tommy do you think it's
worse than alcohol for example
well Hey listen I'm not here to say if
it's worse or better than alcohol I do
know that there are more studies that
are surfacing saying that the long-term
effects of cannabis might be a little
different than some people think but
when we talk about alcohol people
usually don't look at an alcoholic and
say yeah that's safe that's healthy
that's environmental but when you look
at people that habitually smoke weed
there's this connotation that comes with
it that it's from the earth it's natural
it's for the hippies well take a longer
look into that and I think the studies
are going to reveal that it might not be
so green wholesome and wonderful on down
the road so it's really more the
connotation that goes with it people
have been told it's natural it's healthy
there's nothing wrong with it you can't
OD on it and I think that's a very
dangerous message to be putting out
there especially young people I mean it
might be a dangerous message but it's
actually a fact I believe that no one's
ever medically OD'd on cannabis whereas
a lot of people have OD'd on alcohol
alcohol seems to kill a lot more people
than cannabis does I'm not necessarily
advocating that we Legalize It here I'm
just saying those are two facts which
make it interesting to me that we treat
as a society alcohol in a more liberal
tolerant way than we treat cannabis and
I'm not quite sure why
well I think also you mentioned nobody's
OD'd well that might be the case but
just because you're not overdosing and
dying doesn't mean that there are not
adverse effects and I think we need to
know those adverse effects for so long
you know the weed lobbying industry has
said oh it's clean it's natural there's
no problem you're not going to OD on it
again a dangerous message let's also
keep in mind that here in the United
States we're having a big problem with
marijuana being laced with fentanyl so
this message that oh it's just weed well
listen you gotta look a little deeper
got to get a little further under the
hood and then we also have to understand
that because we don't have uniform
regulation a lot of this weed that's
being grown the fertilizer is being used
are not being regulated the right way so
there are other health side effects that
go along with this Beyond just overdose
that really need to be looked at and
we've got to get under the hood a little
deeper okay but just final point back to
you uh Sean does anything Tommy say
there yeah make you rethink what you're
what you're saying about this well okay
okay so how does turning weed into a I
say drug solved the problem you know
we've got a South American country there
where the prime minister or the
president has basically told you know
his cops to go out and end people's
lives on the street anyone who's doing
drugs shoots him right kill him and and
that doesn't stop him doing it so how
does turning it giving it a Class A
solve that problem and and and and
really what so we blame him the whole
problem of homelessness and no jobs and
everything else in America on what we
really
come on
all right let's go with the final word
to You Tommy Lauren come on
growled in a mancunian accent no I'm not
saying our homeless crisis I'm not
saying our homeless crisis can can
entirely be blamed on weed it's mostly
blamed on Democrats and there are
policies here in the United States but
I'll tell you this the cities and the
states that have legalized they have
seen an influx of degenerates on their
streets that come there because the weed
has been legalized it doesn't attract
the best of the best go to Denver
Colorado go to Los Angeles go to San
Francisco tell me what you see and I'd
also say this about the whole gateway
drug thing not a lot of individuals
start out with a needle in their arm
they start out with something else so is
it a domino effect uh I have a feeling
that there's something to that you know
what it's a fascinating debate and I
can't think of two more unlikely people
to have come together to have it and yet
you both made great points so I think we
should we may have to do this pairing
again
um thank you both very much Sean Tommy
really appreciate it thanks please
come to my pack I mean it's a great
actually pairing there you could meet
two more unlikely people to Duke it out
but interesting points Esther they both
made interesting points this is a very
complex issue I think I think so and I
actually I understand Tommy's point
because it's it's mostly I'm sort of
unleashing Pandora's Box I think the
status quo now is fine I don't think we
should make it a Class A drug because
we're dedicating too many resources it's
something that's not as big of a problem
we're already tackling the problem it is
interesting when I go I have a house in
L.A right so I gather a lot and it's
amazing how quickly it's moved to where
you walk down the main part of Beverly
Hills and you see these gigantic
Billboards all for people flogging
marijuana yep and you're like if you
come from England it's like quite
shocking yeah but there's completely
accepted and they're just cracked on and
I don't think it's as bad as Tommy
presented there from my from my look at
it but I certainly do get the feeling
from a lot of people that it's more
dangerous to certain types of people
than than I think there's no societal
benefit for legalizing weed and I say
this not not including the medicinal
uses of cannabis I say this as you're
not going to get a better Society
because more people are smoking weed
legally but I also don't think you
should dedicate more State resources to
try and tackle it like you would deal
with Heroin I think the problem is with
alcohol for instance it's Pandora's Box
we've opened it we have a very much an
alcohol consuming society and that leads
to so many illnesses that our NHS has to
deal with you don't want to add to that
now by either legalizing weed or you're
nodding me you agree with that
I do actually I think it's Class B at
the moment I think that's about right
they did move it down to class A they
rapidly moved it back up to class B I I
also think there are certain elements of
um our Multicultural Society where
smoking cannabis is is part of their
cultural part of their culture and I
think in in those situations it is
unfair they are being penalized for
something that is completely natural to
their to their culture but it is also
true what Tommy is saying and this is
where the argument gets a little bit
nuanced is there is a lot of cannabis
and weed out there which is being laced
with stuff that is incredibly different
absolutely yeah and especially if young
kids get their hands on it but is
legalizing going to make that different
because you would then yes you would
have you would have legalized forms of
cannabis which are probably so you need
to write fine for you and it's regulated
that isn't going to stop the strongest
stuff being on the black market yeah but
then you could have you could have
tougher laws couldn't you for for we
that's being sold on the black market I
mean to Tommy's point about fentanyl
being laced in a legal regulated product
that's obviously not happening and if
that is happening that would be like if
we started selling alcohol in our shops
that was made from moonshine it's just
it's just not plausible but also would
you would you legalize it here I don't I
don't think I would Legalize It I would
definitely say we should decriminalize
it I think when you look at America and
you think about over half of the people
who are in prison because for drug
offenses are because of weed which is a
really light drug and really can't
affect you it's just abysmal I don't
know why on Earth okay take a little
break come back and talk about Kanye
West who's been suspended from social
media for anti-semitic Brands we're
going to talk to the Jewish actor
Michael Russell thought about this he's
livid about this and we'll get our
reaction from the pack it's after the
parade plus one in three people born
this year will get dementia and claim
the life of national British treasure
Barbara Windsor and her widower Scott
Mitchell will be here with a tough
message for the government who he thinks
may be about to reneg on promises made
to commit funding to dementia we'll
discuss that
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to baseball and Center
Canada west side is controversy to spot
a global debate about the line between
free speech and hate speech as well as
concerns about his mental health last
week he wore a white lives matter
teacher at a Paris fashion show but it
was Twitter posts about going in his
words death Con 3 on Jewish people The
Stoke the biggest outrage he's now been
suspended by Twitter and Instagram and
condemned by a host of Jewish
celebrities comedian and actor Michael
Rapaport who's previously defended Kanye
is one of his critics this time and he
joins me now and Michael thank you very
much indeed for joining me
what's up Pierce well good to have you
and I I was reading your or watching
your video uh attack we've got a little
clip over here let's just take a look at
this first
kooky Kanye West what are you talking
about Defcon one
Defcon 2cc Jews we know about Defcon 3
defconf you're not doing Defcon anything
with the Jews we we know about that
Defcon five six million we know all
about that
I gotta say it Michael that was my
response and I'm not Jewish I'm an Irish
Catholic but when I saw what he'd
written I was trying to think what would
I feel if I had been Jewish reading this
hugely influential rap Superstar talking
about going dead you didn't even say def
conference he said d-e-a-t-h is this
almost a to Ram it home when you first
saw it what was your reaction
I I mean I I didn't like it I was
offended by it
um I I didn't like it I was offended by
it you know I'm I I uh I'm offended by
that kind of talk I'm offended by you
know when when there's any sort of
racist or racial anti-semitic talk
um and I you know and I just I just you
know spoke my mind like I I do about
about a lot of a lot of things you know
I didn't like it you know um I um feel
like it's an obligation and and it's
something that I must do as a as a man
as a Jewish man and as a celebrity uh
who's Jewish um to to speak out because
you know in my opinion and you know
statistically anti-some anti-Semitism is
on the rise in the United States I don't
know what it is worldwide
um and a lot of times you know we will
speak on behalf of other people's causes
and other situations but not our own and
and I don't like the stereotypes uh that
are portrayed um you know in my business
sometimes about you know Men Jewish men
being passive or just you know neurotic
and you know guilt-ridden and it's just
not something that it's just not a um
something that I'll I'll Stand By and
not say anything you know just like I
didn't say anything during the uh
Charlottesville uh situation when they
were saying Jews will not replace us and
you will not replace US during the Trump
regime so so then my next question is I
completely concur what you just said but
he's been suspended by various social
media firms should he be completely no
platform I mean people like Donald Trump
aren't allowed to be I don't think
social media
I I don't think what you can no I I
think Donald Trump got what he he asked
for I think he pushed the envelope I've
been suspended on all social media
platforms Twitter Facebook Instagram the
big three of and you know if if you
can't if you can't um do the time don't
do the crime there's rules and
regulations I don't think that he should
be taken off of it
um and at this point you know who am I
to say but I I get the suspensions I've
gotten suspensions for language and
stuff like that and it's it's part of
the uh The Forum you know it sucks it's
frustrating when it happens to me I
could say when it happens to me but it's
part of the game you know there's so
many benefits
um especially for someone in show
business especially for someone on Kanye
like Kanye and all entertainers to be on
social media to promote themselves and
to promote uh um products and stuff like
that and and uh you know sometimes you
need to a time out it's happened to me
like I said it sucked but I don't think
he should be removed completely no okay
I mean very interesting well Michael
thank you very much indeed for that
perspective when I come come back to the
back here so Esther you were defending
Kanye West which I was surprised about
because to me it was a clear cut
breach of any rule you want to see if
you're blatantly making threats to a
whole populist particularly Jewish
people
then I'm sorry you cross a line don't
you that's a free speech the thing is
though I'm I'm very cut and dry what I
think um social media platforms have the
right to regulate because I think
they're taking the Mickey right you do
not get to say that we are we are a
platform and not a publisher and yet
sense of things that you don't like my
the only caveat I have to that is you
have to explicitly call for violence if
you said that on this show tonight you
wouldn't be back here tomorrow but
you're not if I said it about if I said
I'm going to go Defcon 3 on black people
I probably wouldn't work again in this
country
I'm not defending what he said I do
think and where you are though what you
mean is there's no line there I I do not
think that social media platforms have
the right to regulate that kind of
speech why no because because because
the thing is because that falls
because it's not inside and he's not
inciting violence
no it's not inciting violence it's hate
speech that's a difference and the
reason why the difference is let's go
Defcon on Jewish people that's inciting
violence I'm going definitely he said
when I wake up in the morning I'm gonna
go Defcon 3 on Jewish people that's
literally what's up how do you know
because he hasn't said what he's going
to do does he need to Ava well I don't
know is that what they were saying in
like 1938 like but not it's not it's not
inciting violence and I'm very black and
white about this I'm very black and
white I don't think I do not think
social media platforms should regulate
hate speech because I think it's very
subjective new refusing to use someone's
pronouns for example racism is not but
inciting violence is the only caveat
okay so anti-Semitism should it be
tolerated by any social media platform
they obviously have the right their
private company to do with their life I
think they'd be very inconsistent
actually in targeting conservative
people like Trump and letting our color
ramsdale but in terms of what Kanye said
to me it's completely unacceptable yeah
I mean he's obviously not fit to be on
there is he and it is a private company
they should absolutely take him off and
also we should have better regulation
like what happened to that online harms
bill that we were supposed to put
through last Parliament session that
didn't go through that was supposed to
regulate all of this I can't believe
we're not in a situation yet where you
have to put your credit card details in
to have a social media account well this
is the I mean the problem isn't it Emily
is it how do you regulate it when a lot
of countries like kids in you know Egypt
and the Arabs bring Uprising kids in
Iran now kids in China they want to be
anonymous on social media in case they
get hunted down and potentially put in
jail for having their right to free
speech this is the argument against
making everybody have to give their
details and say who they are I mean I've
got to agree with you it is it is a
really tricky subject because yes by
people being anonymous it also allows
Bots it's much harder for social media
platforms to track down Bots and we've
seen huge disinformation from Russia
because of that and and other countries
but you're absolutely right in Iran
right now if there's someone on social
media who is saying you know death to
the eyes or Russia or anything you're
you know you're in really deep trouble
and and a lot of social media is the
only way they're getting out the videos
that they need to say what's actually
happening in their countries I I think
the biggest problem is we've allowed
these social media platforms to become
so big so powerful with such large
audiences it's almost become an
impossible that's that's an impossible
thing to regulate well that's why in a
way in a way but we're all sitting here
under publisher rules we have rules
there's often which is the television
regulator and they'll be watching all
these programs and they if people
complain they investigate we can't say
we there are things we can't say but
also we wouldn't
I just literally put myself into the
shoes that if I said that on air what
would happen I would have been fired
immediately and quite right it might be
quite right and you wouldn't work again
no well it's a little bit it's like well
can you know he's a bit weird isn't he
so he gets away with it
um what would you all think if I did
this to you in an emoji you message me
and I went well in Afghanistan that's a
swear word
Afghanistan if I send you a thumbs up
emoji yeah what would you feel if we're
not having an argument I would think
you're being passive aggressive you
would absolutely really yes yes
oh if we're having an argument oh it's
an argument yeah God I sent someone a
thumbs up this evening but we weren't
having an argument he just said anything
should we have a drink and I went thumbs
up
well apparently I thread on reddit.com
says generation Zed you're of course
offended and upset by absolutely
everything they see the thumb up emoji
as you two you generation Zeds yeah just
about
um is it as rude or passive aggressive
whereas people over 35 are more like to
use it I mean I I do all the time to
people I'm not being passive against
yeah exactly
you and your wife are having a tiff and
she said something to you and you did
that that we don't have this because she
knows how lucky she is
but no my sons for example when I watch
that girl I'll often do that and it'll
be like I suppose it is slightly passive
aggressive sometimes yeah yeah exactly
yeah shall we go out for a drink yeah
exactly that's fine no it's not cool by
the way neither is the laughing face so
I realized how I'm cool I was because I
put laughing faces on everything just
because I'm laughing but that is so well
David Cameron famously put LOL didn't he
at the end of his emails thinking it
meant lots of love laugh out loud and in
fact to be taught to be told it means
Lots
you've said lots of love and actually he
was laughing yeah
I only have people my age or more than
we can love the senior moment no one
cares you've got to speak to your sons
more they'll they'll they do try and
they'll be cringing of that now
um quickly before we go to the break Liz
truss talking of thumbs down right
actually let's talk about it after the
break we'll have a quick break and come
back and talk about this trials is she
toast and if she's not toast why isn't
she and also we're gonna Scott Mitchell
of course Barbara Windsor's winner a
great guy with a very important message
he fears that one of the one of the many
downsides of what is going on with our
uh who finances at the moment is that it
may impact directly on people with
dementia he's gonna explain why it's
going to be with me
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
Start Spreading the News beers is taking
the show to New York City with big
guests in the Big Apple heavyweight
champion Mike Tyson the most
controversial man in American News
sucker Carson and the man who tried to
kill the President John Hinckley Jr and
many more join Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City
foreign
[Music]
Big Apple will be coming next week all
week uh live from Manhattan uh welcome
back though to tonight's show Dane
Barbara Windsor was an icon on and off
the screen for seven decades she was a
nation's sweetheart in legendary
carry-on movies
oh matron take them away and she became
the nation's beloved landlady is Peggy
Mitchell in EastEnders remember this
iconic clip
that's for you Pat now you're yes
I'm not going anywhere
until about my drinks
fantastic stuff well Barbara was made a
Dame by the Queen Elizabeth in 2016 but
in private she's already battling the
illness that meant she could sometimes
no longer remember even her own
glittering career she was cared for by
her husband Scott until her death in
2020. former prime minister Boris
Johnson launched a national mission to
tackle Dementia in Dame Barbara's memory
but tonight that mission they'd be under
threat we'll discuss that in a moment
well joining me now is Dane Barbara's uh
widower husband Scott great to see you
Scott good to see you guys are even
looking at Barbara there the footage
reminds me a how brilliantly talented
she was what fun she was on and off
camera but also much we all missing and
for you of course it must be unbearable
your new book by your side my life
loving Barbara Windsor just has his
dedication to my Barbara A Love Like No
Other always in my heart always miss
forever love your Scott yeah and and I
do and I do and I miss her every day and
we were a very kind of close couple
because we we didn't do the kind of
separate holidays and things like that
together other I mean we were always
together people always said you know
this little unit walked into little
munchkins turned up somewhere and of
course you have to get on and you have
to live your life and you have to start
to try and live again but it's different
you you live but it's different and I
just miss everything about her I just
miss our silly little inane chats we
didn't start talking for 27 years
amazing thing when you first got
together it was a big age gap of 26 26
years yeah and it reminds me in a way of
Dame Joan Collins another great Dame of
this country and her husband Percy the
first year age Captain they've been
together over 20 years now yeah uh two
of the best marriages I've seen actually
which just said to me age has got
nothing to do with it it's about
compatibility absolutely finding the
right person for you that gives you real
love and support absolutely and the
other thing I think that that we had we
liked each other yes and I think that's
such an important element of a
relationship do I like this because if
you don't I think a lot of people don't
even Millers so many people I know spit
up since the pandemic because they
actually had to spend a lot of time with
their other half and discover they don't
even like each other that is exactly the
point is it going to work all day and
they sort of they sleep all night and
they work out actually you've got to
live together yeah I didn't like it it's
easy to say I love you we all say I love
you people we're saying that to people
the whole time yeah but to actually like
someone to want to be with them in that
close proximity all those years then
that's a really big thing I had a great
pleasure of interviewing Barbara for my
life story show and there was a
wonderful moment right at the end when I
asked her how she'd like to be
remembered and she said this
you could write your own obituary would
you prefer it to say world's most famous
giggle dies or world's most famous
cleavage
all right I'd like um she was a good
bird
what's lovely about that is that
actually on her tombstone is that phrase
she was a good bird it came from the
life stories answer absolutely which I
think was really lovely and touching
yeah there's a plaque cup at golders
Green crematorium that I've had put in
one of the courtyards and that is the
bottom line yeah she was a good bird I
love that yeah um let's get serious so
you set up uh this big campaign to try
and get people support and to remember
Barbara the right way and Boris Johnson
was going to commit a lot of money like
yes 95 95 million pounds yeah to do this
you now have information I think that's
come your way that because of all this
economic turmoil that's going on this
may not now happen what do you know
absolutely now if I'm wrong about this
fine then I'll then I'll apologize but I
have it on very very good
source of information that two things
could possibly happen that have already
been put in place that will affect
people in a major way
the first thing is the the Dane Barbara
wins a dementia mission was brought
about a call from Alzheimer's research
UK who I'm an ambassador for we called
for a task for similar based on what the
kobit vaccine was I did a zoom
conference with Dame Kate Bingham who
headed up the code task force and we
said if we can put the same premise for
dementia which is now so number one
Killers why do you think it may not
happen
I've been told that the interviews to
start putting people in place for the
task force should have started two weeks
ago they were canceled at the last
minute and they were told it's to do
with
um government issues about budget sign
off
this is exactly what I feared was going
to happen yeah in this financial turmoil
they're going to have to make a lot of
cuts despite saying they're not and
things like this vitally important
campaigns which you've done such
brilliant work on yeah are going to get
screwed in the process if that happens
how are you going to feel I'm going to
feel absolutely disgusted what is your
message to Liz truss and quasi quattane
tonight they cannot do this dementia is
costing the economy 26 billion a year
this task force set up they are going to
start trials and developing new drugs it
will take two to three years to get
those into the system anyway you start
delaying that now peers and we're
talking about another five or six years
and you also have heard that maybe cuts
to social care as well well the other
thing that was put in by the previous
prime minister was he's the first Prime
Minister in 70 years and 14 prime
ministers to have actually put something
in place to do something about the
social care and that may be a threat as
well that one there's an 86 000 pound
cap which comes in in October 2023 I've
also heard that that could be
significantly delayed or it could be
kicked down I think I'm glad you come on
to say this I think it'll be an absolute
disgrace yeah if either or both of those
things happen the idea that these things
get targeted to save money because these
two clowns running the country have
screwed our finances would be a
completely contemptible thing so we'll
keep on this Scott I I've got to say
It's a Wonderful book about a wonderful
lady I loved your love story you proved
all the critics and skeletons wrong and
we'll all miss their dreadfree not least
you but thanks for coming in and go read
this by your side it's a wonderful book
uh good to see you Scott thank you
that's it from me whatever you're up to
Keep It Uncensored that's the way
Barbara and Scott would certainly are
wanted it good night
[Music]
foreign